[Music]
hey time once again for new movies new
horror movies yeah the one we're doing
today we found this one on I think this
just went to be owed a VOD like a couple
weeks ago and I'd been seeing it like
coming up in the thing I'm like that
looks pretty good maybe I should like
watch that this is called we some in the
darkness okay yeah I think know which
one you were gonna start off with I like
this movie I liked this movie very very
much it was another one in the same line
if you guys remember like probably a
couple months ago we reviewed that movie
satanic panic which is on shudder this
one is streaming I think we've rented
this one on Xbox this one's not on
shudder yet I don't think but um it's
this one's kind of like a similar vibe
to that one although I did like satanic
panic but I think I liked this one
better it's taking place in the 80s yeah
it's what your 1988 and they had the
heavy metal scene and they got a lot of
it right a lot of it's wrong you know we
grew up during that time period but when
I talk about wrong and wrong
fashion-wise but it doesn't really
affect the story that of the movie you
know I like the tone it was kind of like
a a fun horror movie tone there's a lot
of twists in it can't really say too
much about the story without spoiling it
it's a brand new movie so you gotta not
say much yeah I don't really want to
spoil it but it's about these [ __ ]
three hot heavy-metal chicks going to a
concert and [ __ ] they hook up with
these three heavy metal guys and they're
trying to party and everything and turns
out there's like some satanic murders
going on at the time and like around the
country around that country or whatever
so one thing leads to another you know
what I mean it just it was a good movie
I liked it me too I think one of the
best things about it we I should note
that one of the guy that plays one of
the heavy metal guys is the same guy
that played the boyfriend and Alita
battle angel yeah I came over the actors
name and then it's guy what's his name
from johnny Knoxville Johnny Knoxville's
in it he plays a straight role he plays
a role of a [ __ ] televangelist yeah
that's a pretty good job he's not in it
a lot but it's like he really does bring
a lot to that
he's always kind of like I don't know
there's there's something like really
sinister about like the way he plays it
and stuff which i think is really cool
yeah I didn't know johnny Knoxville
could act I mean I'm not talking about
Citizen Kane or anything you know I mean
it's just he pulled the roll off yeah
I'm like I said he's probably only in it
for about five minutes yeah total yeah
um what they got wrong was the hair the
hair that it wasn't big enough the hair
wasn't big enough and it wasn't
feathered out on the sides well they'd
probably be too distracting I think I
feel like it would probably be yeah
acting and have you metal girls from
this period mostly have fringe on their
jackets and their [ __ ] boots remember
those [ __ ] fringe now I will note
that one of the girls did have one of
those very accurate like big huge
fringed purses yeah so if that [ __ ] was
over the top I mean you'd see that [ __ ]
and [ __ ] you'd hear and you'd hear
[ __ ] you know you know like a cowboy
on a steel horse I ride you know [ __ ]
the [ __ ] Fringe and [ __ ] it looked
tacky as [ __ ] it did yeah so they kind
of cleaned him up a little bit for the
modern audience they're cute girls yeah
when I'm kind of had like a Madonna vibe
going on like a heavy-metal Madonna the
other one come I don't know you just
gotta check out yourself yeah there was
one of the best things about this there
was also this is okay this weirded me
out
so the actress that's in it Amy Forsythe
who plays kind of like the quiet girl
that's like going along with all this
now she was also I knew she looked
familiar
but I was thinking for some reason I was
thinking it was Abigail Breslin who was
in Haunter and she was in the zombie
land movies and stuff and then I looked
at the credits and I was like wait
that's not the same girl that was in
even though she looked like eerily
similar I'm like are they [ __ ]
related what is going on so then I
looked at both their Wikipedia pages and
I was looking at pictures of them next
to each other I'm like oh yeah I guess
it's not the same girl this girl that
was in this Amy Forsythe she was in
Hellfest and she was also in season two
of channel zero so that's probably where
I had seen her before even though I
thought she was Abigail Breslin for the
whole [ __ ] movie but um one of the
best things about this movie is the
interplay between the three girls like
particularly the two that are like the
the ringleaders I guess like the Madonna
girl
like the other one like the dark-haired
girl you know I think the the
dark-haired girl her character name was
Alexis and then the Madonna looking one
was named Val and the way the two of
them like interacted with each other
like the interplay between them
it was totally believable that these two
girls had been friends for like years
and years and years you know what I mean
it was just a very organic kind of
friendship that they had and I totally
bought it
and also the care all the characters in
this um even you know bad ones are
actually really strangely likeable and
compelled like you want to watch them
because it's just fun and even when
they're just like hanging out in the
backyard like drinking and you know
shooting the [ __ ] and stuff like that
they're still like really entertaining
yeah and likeable like you're there
hanging out with them like I really
liked that vibe to it know the guy that
was in a later battle and what was his
name again you know what his real name
is I can't remember what that he's in it
man he's a couple years older now and I
liked him and he did a good job on the
road and he's looking [ __ ] nice and
lean and [ __ ] if you were to have like
maybe put like another three or four
years on him and maybe another five or
six pounds on him I would have proved
true for him to enter the crustle sphere
and play the new snake but I went with I
think Holly make a good snake even make
a good Snake Plissken just have him do
put my patch on him [ __ ] long hair
and thinking you know I mean do a
[ __ ] Clint Eastwood impressa Nate
impersonation and that would be snake
he'd be good snake it's interesting
because in Aleta which I guess was you
know a year or two ago he seemed like
much younger like he doesn't seem old in
this one but he's definitely like
matured so he seems like an older guy
and he comes across with a lot more
gravitas because I guess in Alya he was
much more of like an opportunistic you
know more of a teenager type character
but in this he was like you know older
in his twenties guy and he had to kind
of like and you know I don't like you
know mullets and I don't like that whole
like heavy metal look and stuff but that
kind of suited him like the mustache and
stuff like I thought he looks kind of
cool like he kind of had heroic
qualities to him in the movie and this
one
the course they made him take his shirt
off which I proved that too because he
was in good shape it's not a she he's
very lean looking he's not massive is
lean and snake was kind of lean so I you
know I was going like mad did he could
pull off Snake Plissken in a couple
years he probably could yeah better now
that you're ready yeah because it's not
so big you know me [ __ ] snake is a
midsize guy yeah I mean I think this
guy's actually a little bit smaller
he might be my size and height that I'm
not sure but still that worked - yeah
snakes gotta be in the story you know
snake has got to be kind of like
physically and numerically outmatched
all time but he still comes up [ __ ]
winning yeah he does it through well I
think that was something that I would I
liked him about some of those type of
action movies were you know ones like
die hard and stuff like that which is
kind of like a relatively normal guy yet
had to kind of like find their strength
and fight back against him you know it's
like I like ones like predator and stuff
like that to where it's just like a
bunch of like big muscley dudes yeah
it's a different type of strength it's a
different type of yeah yeah snake was
about being slippery that's exactly what
they were talking about he was [ __ ]
sneaky yes sneaky and crafty and that's
you know I think that kid could pull off
snake eye they say they're gonna remake
it I don't well it would shock me if
they didn't get around to it at some
point because they've remade pretty much
everything and price [ __ ] evens even
stuff that was like less popular than
that movie but you know I mean even
carpenter [ __ ] it up so it's like
what's what chance is somebody else that
if they're gonna [ __ ] let somebody
direct escape from New York a remake of
it you have the dude who [ __ ] um
directed at VFW do it yeah what was that
guy you'd remember his name the guy
directed if ya gonna make it [ __ ] he
can make a Snake Plissken movie yeah cuz
he's like he's really know he
understands like that even though like I
said he made Bliss tune you know like
that was a job a ghost Vegas yeah that's
the thing but yeah so this movie oh I
should note that this was actually
directed by Mark Myers who also fun fact
directed my friend Dahmer which I still
haven't seen yet even though everyone
has recommended it to me it's really
really good
um so I haven't seen it yet but this
movie
it's just like I said if you'd like to
satanic panic this is kind of in the
same vein as that although it has like a
lot more twist to it the character work
I liked a lot more in this one it's not
as funny as satanic panic I don't think
I think the the humor and this one comes
more out of like the relationships in
the situation more than it just being
kind of like gags you know what I'm
saying also some pretty decent gore in
this you know it seemed like there was
it was pretty bloody but you know if
this is just like a really fun like 80s
throwback horror comedy with just like
really cool characters and it's very
simple and like I said it's got some
twists so you can like you know I'm not
gonna spoil anything cuz I think it
would kind of ruin it cuz I didn't I
kind of suspected how it was gonna go
but I wasn't sure exactly like how it
was gonna go you know what I mean good
score - classical score I liked it
uh yeah I did like I did like the score
as well but then didn't they use like
some actual I kinda used to like a
merciful fainted Kingdom I knew it was
somebody like that and I laughed because
they used heaven is a place on earth
yeah yeah even though I thought when
they played it in the movie I was like
oh it's temple into Carlisle song but I
guess it was a cover because I looked at
the thing at the end and it didn't say
Belinda Carlisle but I remember Belinda
Carlisle doing that song but yeah so
this it's streaming everywhere and like
I said I think it uh I think it
premiered at a festival like last year
like early last year but it only just
came to be OD I think in April of this
year so definitely if you're into horror
comedies and like just fun eighties
style yeah movies like that then check
it out I had a lot of fun with it and a
lot of thought it was a blast a lot of
these retro movies that we've been
recommending lately man have really been
[ __ ] good well you have to think that
the people making them are big fans of
you know John Carpenter they're fans of
those types of movies to pry around our
age so they kind of [ __ ] grew up
watching the same movies we were
watching you know I imagine a lot of
them or even if they're younger like cuz
I think a lot of younger people are kind
of into that and see turbo kid if you
guys haven't seen it yeah we talked
about that on the terminal side tracks
it's a good movie yeah that was a that
was also on do we rent that off Xbox
Jamie yes
somewhere to you because I'm like I said
the ones the ones that you can rent on
Xbox you can usually rent them on
YouTube and yeah they're evidently work
on a sequel to turbo kid I heard that
yeah which you know I they should
totally do that because that's a that's
totally a world that can be opened up
but yeah we've some in the darkness uh
definitely check it out
[Music]